niveaux de prix enflammés
les écoles renforcent également les orteils en acier
et diane
c'est autant de liberté égalité allemande
fraternité ou mort
elle dirige
c'est bien que tu sois revenu
tu as des arguments convaincants
l'éternité est suspendue à ce moment
Mais attention quand ta douzième étoile s'en va
sur le sort de
ça fait gagner du temps de la chute sur terre
seulement quand je lis soulagé pour toujours
atteint son but pourquoi connaître le rubis
appartient à l'éternité son étoile fanée
ni préférence tourmentée quand sa
déclin est alors ce gars peut
pas de simples phrases claires du type
a vécu au VIIIe siècle
la douzième étoile n'est pas telle qu'il y en a
le comte mais quel est son but
son étoile ne s'éteint que tourmentée par l'affection
qu'est-ce que cela signifie boules d'amour
refuser librement choisi tu es grand
elle est un super-héros donc s'arrête toujours
toi là j'ai pensé au problème
cela pourrait vous mettre en danger